[Musique]
bonjour François patriars
de la Côte d'Or vous préciser le groupe
RDPI c'est le groupe des sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour un interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par crescel Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour François Patriot on va parler
immigration pour commencer François
Patriat Gérald Darmanin était à Rome
hier soir rencontrer son homologue après
l'arrivée de milliers de migrants sur
les côtes italienne à lompés 12a Gérard
Darmanin qui affiche un message de
fermeté nous devons protéger les
frontières extérieures de l'Union
européenne est-ce que la France va
prendre sa part et accueillir une partie
des migrants de l'empets de 12 ans
fermeté humanité efficacité dans ce
triptyque il y a effectivement la
conduite de la France telle qu'elle
entend être menée bien sûr que la France
prendra sa partie il faut d'abord il
faut que le pacte migratoire on passe
d'être signe à Bruxelles soit signé je
crois que Bruxelles avance aujourd'hui
sur ce fait mais il y a déjà une règle
qui permet aujourd'hui de répartir ce
qu'a dit
on va en accueillir ce qu'a dit Gérald
darmenin était clair il a dit nous
accepterons nous laisserons entrer sur
le territoire ceux qui peuvent ont
obtenir qui peuvent espérer avoir un
titre de séjour donc la France prendra
sa barre alors que d'autres ont dit non
aujourd'hui la France a accueilli les
bateaux quand l'Italie n'en voulait pas
la France voulait dire la doctrine de la
France c'est humanité fermeté efficacité
donc il est normal par exemple d'avoir
ouvert un centre d'accueil à Menton j'ai
entendu dire qu'il y avait des hôtels
qui étaient réservés je ne pense
démenti par le préfet qui assemble
d'accueil donc je peux vous donner plus
d'informations qu'il aime mais la France
va accueillir à Menton en tous les cas
visiblement des réfugiés qui viennent de
l'embête tout ça quelle que soit les
conditions c'est ce qui a été décidé
apparemment apparemment je n'ai pas pu
pas plus d'informations que vous sur le
sujet mais effectivement j'ai vu des
chambres avaient été mais pas un centre
d'accueil c'est pas une arrivée
ce message de fermeté à la fois dire
ceux qui vous disent aujourd'hui on
accepte personne on ferme les frontières
complètement
national Marine Le il faut en accueillir
aucun des micro-ondes
dans une posture d'une opposante
irresponsable
qui elle-même je suis convaincu une
croix parce qu'elle dit exactement qui
fait aujourd'hui ce que disent madame
Meloni avant d'être élu qu'elle allait
arrêter les bateaux en mer et cetera qui
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que sont l'aide
de l'Europe elle n'y arrivera pas
compris on sait très bien aujourd'hui
que les fanfaronnades que les
affirmations brutales même parfois
inhumanité
inhumanitaire ne sont pas applicables
ensuite et qu'ensuite il faudra bien
vous avez compris tout le monde devient
compris qu'il n'y a de solutions que
européenne aujourd'hui que c'est
difficile effectivement que la règle que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure qui est fermé
c'est de celle aussi bien sûr tendue de
ne pas d'accueillir les gens dans des
conditions décentes quand ils viennent
de risquer leur vie en mer de faire en
sorte qu'il soit traité humainement mais
vous la trouvez que la solution
européenne quand l'Allemagne dit que
elle veut pas en accueillir justement si
le pacte migratoire aujourd'hui est en
discussion à Bruxelles c'est pour que
certains reviennent sur la décision et
qu'on arrive à un accord
on vous sentez prudent sur les mots et
sur la manière dont ces réfugiés vont
être accueillis à mentons on entend
beaucoup ce sera temporaire ça n'est pas
un centre d'accueil on sent la majorité
le gouvernement à tâtons sur ce sujet-là
vous craignez vraiment l'opinion
publique sur ces questions je pense pas
je pense pas que je pense qu'on peut
parler à l'opinion publiquement une
radicalité
avec précaution c'est un sujet vous
l'avez compris quelle perdemment
hypersensible qui est douloureux qui est
difficile qui ne se traitent pas comme
ça au départ des déclarations par des
incantations
inefficaces ça se traite je crois par la
diplomatie ça se traite par par aussi de
façon j'allais dire aussi juste que
possible pour que le maximum de gens qui
puissent entrer enfin qui puisse le
maximum de gens qui puissent obtenir des
papiers le soir ça nécessite de la
concertation moi je ne suis pas gêné
dans cette affaire
l'immigration c'est pas fini elle se
profile dans les années qui viennent
plus difficiles encore donc traiter
aujourd'hui le problème à court terme en
disant il y a qu'à faucon ça n'existe
pas ça n'existe pas ce que fait Marine
Le Pen pour vous je vous ai dit je
voudrais répondu ce que tu as Marine Le
Pen je pense que toutes les droites
extrêmes qui ont préconisé le blocage
total le renvoie intégral etc d'ailleurs
renvoyé ou partout qu'est-ce que vous
faites si vous renvoyez les gens à Tunis
aujourd'hui 15 jours après ils
reprennent l'autre passeur pour revenir
sur quoi elle est renvoyé à Tunis
aujourd'hui c'est quoi donc là vous
dites il faut accueillir c'est un peu le
message que le pape est venu porter
enfin va venir porter à Marseille ce
week-end
il dit que la Méditerranée est devenue
un cimetière et qu'il faut plus
d'humanité envers les migrants
c'est quelque chose qui peut être dit
aujourd'hui en France ça encore
en tout cas nous le disons nous le
disons que dans ce domaine bien entendu
il faut traiter avec l'humanité quand on
sait qu'il y a eu 2000 morts en
Méditerranée cette année sans doute
sous-estimé beaucoup enfants ou de
femmes dire aujourd'hui il suffit
d'arrêter les bateaux en mer ou
d'arrêter les passeurs en mer
c'est-à-dire le faire je pense que le
pape et dans son rôle
ne disait pas cela je me dirais quel est
le rôle du Pape le président de la
République lui jusqu'à présent a eu un
discours de fermeté sur l'immigration
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il doit reprendre
la parole pour nuancer ses propos et
parler aussi d'accueil la feuille il a
fait par la voix du ministre de
l'Intérieur il a fait par la voix de la
première ministre aujourd'hui non mais
l'humanité non pas se saisir lui
personnellement de ce dossier
ils sont saisis bien entendu il y a des
conseils avec les premiers ministres
avec le milieu de l'intérieur avec tous
les ministres avec le rôle chaque jour
la parole du président de la République
pèse plus que celle de ces ministres
aujourd'hui on le sait sur l'immigration
et c'est du fruit met deux fois en
disant deux fois publiquement en cours
des dernières semaines pour dire que le
texte de loi immigration
était un texte qui lui tenait à coeur
qu'il voulait qu'il soit présenté au
Parlement avant Noël je vais me couper
qu'il voulait qu'il soit voté totalement
avant Noël mais j'ai compris maintenant
quoi ce qu'elle Assemblée nationale
serait plutôt en janvier
avant Noël donc il a dit à deux reprises
je tiens un texte vous nous confirmez
le projet loi immigration est-ce que
après ces images de Lampedusa le texte
risque de sortir modifié on sait que la
partie sur les régularisations dans les
secteurs en tension était déjà en
question était déjà en danger est-ce que
le texte peut ressortir tronqué
aujourd'hui de cette partie là je disais
avant il faut trouver un texte
d'équilibre je dirais aujourd'hui il
faut un texte de radicalité
il faut que radicalement ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'il faut clairement que les
gens qui ne doivent pas rester sur notre
territoire on donne aujourd'hui les
moyens l'administration à la France de
pouvoir les expulser et de pouvoir les
renvoyer première radicalité deuxième
radicalité il faut qu'à tout prix que
les gens qui peuvent être intégrés dans
notre société qui peuvent trouver
aujourd'hui un métier qui peuvent avoir
droit à un titre de séjour il est
aujourd'hui les entrepreneurs le
demandent mais regardez dans les métiers
de femmes de ménage dans les hôtels dans
les cuisines dans les cuisines
aujourd'hui quand on est bien trois
quarts des gens qui travaillent dans les
cuisines des restaurants sont des gens
qui arrivent
sur le titre de séjour
radicalité doit être quelqu’on le
veuille ou non équilibré il doit y avoir
des mesures de coercition face à ceux
qui n'ont pas de chez nous il doit y
avoir des mesures d'accueil et
d'intégration pour ceux qui peuvent
l'être et dont on a besoin donc je vous
dis hors de question de retirer certains
article ou de le retour qui me concerne
la majorité des groupes de la majorité
soutiendront cette position j'ai cru
comprendre que la gauche le soutiendrait
les socialistes avec tous les groupes de
la majorité parce que tous les groupes
de la majorité parce qu'on a remarqué
que oui on a remarqué qu'Horizon par
exemple n'avait pas signé la tribune qui
a été portée par Sacha Ollier et
quelques gens de la nuque pour défendre
justement cette partie sur les métiers
en tension est-ce que la signature
de quelques personnes
non je n'ai pas les jouets non pas
qu'elle me choque parce que sur le fond
et qui me gêne ce qui me gêne c'est la
méthode et je l'ai dit aux journées
parlementaire à quoi ça sert un jeu
d'appuyer à tout prix pour dire nous
mettons une mise en demeure alors qu'on
sait très bien que ça va exciter et
énerver ce qui n'en veulent pas
aujourd'hui c'est pas la peine dans le
texte est lié le ministre a dit je croy
comprendre qu'ils souhaitait le garder
aussi en tout cas pour ce qui me
concerne c'est pour ça que qu'il n'est
pas cité
présidentielle au Sénat sauf que la
majorités
avec Bruno Retailleau vous non c'est pas
moi qui discute avec Bruno retaille
c'est le gouvernement
je le verrai peut-être je le verrai
peut-être jeudi quand il y aura le roi
d'Angleterre qui sera là je lui en
parlerai sans doute bien entendu mais
comment vous faites alors
ils ont fait beaucoup de lignes rouges
on a vu beaucoup de lignes rouges qu'ils
ont fait sur les retraites la ligne
rouge etc vous savez les personnes les
mesures d'âge les mesures d'inflation
au bout du compte ils avaient obtenu ce
qu'il voulait dans l'une rouge ils n'ont
pas voté après donc je veux bien mais là
vous serez obligé là aussi
moi je souhaite j'espère encore qu'au
Sénat avec la gauche avec la majorité
présidentielle et avec les centristes il
est pas impossible que nous puissions
avoir une majorité sur un texte
équilibré mais est-ce que le compromis
sur cette mesure ça peut être de la
sortir du texte et de la passer par une
circulaire
je sais pas comment c'est légalement
faisable je peux vous répondre à moi si
elle reste une façon d'une autre
ce sera l'équipe aujourd'hui on a
compris qu'un besoin qui vous parcourez
ce pays les pas à l'échelle d'entreprise
vous le demande il y a des métiers que
les Français aujourd'hui
ne veulent plus exercer que des immigrés
acceptent d'exercer ils le font
les entreprises en ont besoin et puis en
plus si que si on dit humanité ça fait
partie du critère humanité que j'ai
évoqué au début le chef de l'État lui a
évoqué la possibilité d'un référendum
sur le sujet l'immigration est-ce que ce
serait de votre point de vue une bonne
idée
et à ce qui pourrait d'abord aujourd'hui
en l'occurrence
c'est pas possible de le faire
il faut donc faire un référendum sur le
référendum donc ça veut dire déjà une
première étape qui prend ah non si on
veut bien regarder les choses le temps
ça se fait pas comme ça un référendum
préparait etc ça se fait pas avant l'été
il sera pas fait en même temps que les
européennes comme le souhaitent monsieur
Bardella vous voyez bien donc déjà
modifier la faire ensuite si on fait une
question sur l'immigration alors moi
j'aimerais bien vous demander à vous
quelle question on pose êtes-vous pour
ou contre l'immigration ça n'a pas de
sens
on va poser la question des quotas par
exemple on peut poser la question de
groupement familial j'entends bien
Emmanuel Macron qu'il faut la poser la
question plus qu'à nous puisque lui il a
ouvert la porte à cette question
d'ouvrir le référendum sur les migration
c'est pas possible j'ai dit
sur ce sujet j'aimerais avant voir
quelle question sera posée voilà mais
bon
ça me paraît difficile aujourd'hui
personnel d'exprimer tes personnel de
faire un référendum sur l'immigration
donc il dit ça pour faire plaisir aux
républicain tout en sachant que ça va
être trop compliqué pour
la République à l'habitude de fermer
aucune porte d'écouter les parties pas
les parties d'opposition des dialoguer
avec eux de chercher des solutions de
trouver des voies on a trouvé pendant un
an sur beaucoup de textes aujourd'hui on
peut le télécharger
si demain on peut effectivement
être caricatural est un peu violente si
vous dites parce que il n'écarte pas une
hypothèse il dit écoutez vous le
souhaitez moi je veux bien qu'on change
le champ du référendum après on verra la
question qu'on pose c'est pas de
non-fumage ça me paraît de la bonne
concertation
on parle d'inflation Elisabeth band va
autoriser la vente à perte pour les
carburants est-ce que c'est un coup dur
pour les petites sessions services
notamment dans le milieu rural que vous
connaissez bien Rosa avait compris que
aujourd'hui chef de l'État qui paye la
facture de toutes les erreurs du passé à
en ce moment avec le gouvernement un
certain nombre de sujets qu'on vient
d'évoquer il y a l'immigration il y a le
climat la sécurité il y a l'inflation le
pouvoir d'achat imaginez bien que tout
est dans ce domaine
que ce soit sur l'environnement soit sur
la sécurité
jamais de gouvernement avant n'a fait
autant qu'elle fait ce gouvernement
depuis 6 ans
et je pourrais vous détailler à l'appui
toutes les sommes qui ont été les plans
qui ont été mis en place sur le
carburant qu'est-ce qui a été déjà fait
sur le carburant le pouvoir d'achat il y
a déjà eu le chèque carburant 100 euros
d'accord bon il y a eu un bouclier
bouclier énergétique Gaz etc et
l'électricité qui a coûté 90 milliards
ne me laissons pas dire aujourd'hui au
gouvernement n'a rien fait pour le
pouvoir d'achat 90 milliards qu'on nous
reproche par ailleurs commettre un
commettre un additif à la dette de la
France les mêmes qui nous reprochent 3
aujourd'hui baisser les taxes baisser
les taxes sur les carburants qu'on nous
le demande d'abord
c'est immédiatement une perte de
recettes pour l'État ça veut dire
matière du public moins de justice moi
décolle moi de gendarmes moins de
policiers c'est tout ça il faut le
savoir
non mais après l'effort qui a été fait
aujourd'hui
le faire que tout le monde participe
l'état participé participe il faut aider
les Français face à cette hausse du
carburant et j'ai vu que le pétrole
encore monté c'est genre des séjours
dernière dans votre question et j'y
viens les petites aujourd'hui la majeure
parce que
il y aura toujours aujourd'hui quand on
prend une décision des notes sont plus
difficiles pour d'autres en l'occurrence
la première ministre a bien dit hier que
quand on en parlera du sujet dans les
semaines qui viennent il y aurait un
plan pour protéger et prendre en compte
les difficultés des petits distributeurs
donc l'état de la participer il va aider
le manomètre c'est pas la même façon que
de mettre tant sur le pack sur le sur le
sur le carburant les déductions il
aidera les petites distributions qui
représentent 20% de la distribution
est-ce que c'est viable à terme parce
qu'on sait que le prix de l'essence ne
va cesser d'augmenter c'est une question
de raréfaction de la des ressources je
trouve bien pessimisme qui vous dit moi
j'ai vu j'ai vu le pétrole monter à plus
de 100 redescendre à 50 ce que j'espère
ce que je souhaite comme le gaz on
disait la même chose le gaz est revenu à
son prix d'origine
sur le pétrole aujourd'hui pour les
raisons géopolitiques pour des raisons
géopolitiques mais moi je j'espère bien
j'espère bien que le carburant
redescendra demain vous savez déjà quand
il était à 51 c'était au on a connu
longtemps le gasoil en 2022 à 25 il est
aujourd'hui à 99,2 bon il faut que il
faut je pense inéluctable non je pense
pas que soyez le top hier soir sur TF1
elle a dit que l'État s'enrichissait en
appauvrissant les contribuables et elle
propose de restituer aux Français une
partie du surplus de la TVA vient un
crédit d'impossible d'y à étudier pour
vous non non
Marine Le Pen a proposé des mesures
d'abord c'est une efficace la baisse de
la TVA c'est inefficace je sois clair
alors d'un côté elle dit qu'il faut plus
s'aider les Français qu'il faut en faire
plus qu'il faut beaucoup plus de
policiers qu'il faut beaucoup de terre
et tout et de l'autre côté un an de 16
de dire que allez il faut faire les
poches de l'état pour
et qu'il faut de façon à ce qu'il est
moindre recettes donc ce qu'elle a
proposé même le 0% vous savez sur les
propos de la cité ça ne se fait passer
récupérer répercuté par ailleurs les
mesures qu'elle propose ont été essayer
dans d'autres pays voir en France et
elles n'ont pas donné les résultats dont
elle parle donc c'est une fausse
promesse et une fausse solution
l'assemblée va reprendre ses travaux la
semaine prochaine avec un texte de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
qui devrait être votée via un 49-3
est-ce que vous au Sénat vous le voterez
écoutez jusqu'à présent le Sénat refusé
de le voter je pense qu'il a il y a un
manque de responsabilités
c'est une attitude politique
pour par lequel ils veulent compenser le
soutien qu'ils ont apporté ici au Sénat
à la réforme des retraites
il demande ils sont toujours dans la
contradiction qui n'est pas elle aura
pas nageur mais de dire tous les jours à
côté il faut plus pour le monde agricole
il faut plus pour le petit commerçant il
faut plus se dire sécurité fous plus
tous les jours j'entends et puis dans le
même temps regardez la dette regardez la
dette de la France n'est pas assez
rigoureux
j'entends bien mais attendez justement
c'est ce que je vous dis les mêmes qui
nous disent ça n'est pas assez rigoureux
dépose des amendements en séance vous
allez le voir sur le web finance
beaucoup plus dépensier bon faut un peu
faut un peu de cohérence et moi je
trouve que aujourd'hui le ministre
d'économie des finances Bruno Le Maire
qui tient le cap le fait avec fermeté il
le fait en ayant révélé quels ont été
les succès de la France il a montré
comment la France se positionne
aujourd'hui et elle est mieux placé que
d'autres dans les domaines comme
l'inflation jusqu'à présent les domaines
comme l'attractivité que dans le même
temps il faut donc
faut comprendre aussi faire comprendre
républicain que de ne pas avoir de
trajectoires financières ça veut dire
perdre l'argent de l'Europe est-ce que
pour est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous dites
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
n'est surtout les textes financiers
surtout et le budget le budget c'est le
c'est le
montoir politique c'est celui qui vous
en politique on vote contre le budget
même un bio indicateur pour la
République ça tient
alors j'adore donc
c'est bien que sur les textes financiers
on va le voir moi je pense qu'il faut
banaliser cela il s'agit pas de
répétition de 49-3 il s'agit il faut
bien que la France ait un budget il y a
ceux qui sont responsabilités qu'il
assume et qui votent le budget qui
accorde les dépenses dans les secteurs
ont besoin qui fait les économies
ailleurs par exemple j'entends par
exemple sur le GNR regarder ce que dit
le gars les agriculteurs aujourd'hui
scandaleux panneaux etc Élodie mais
quand on regarde les chiffres en face le
gna ça fait 100 millions de perdus pour
le mois d'agricoles non pas de perdre je
veux dire de défiscalisation en moi mais
dans le même temps le mois d'agricole va
toucher un milliard un milliard contre
100 millions de la part de l'Europe et
d'autres pour permettre demain la
transition énergétique dans tout le
matériel agricole et ailleurs vous voyez
on parle souvent il faut regarder les
choses dans leur globalité
ça vous paraît pas compliqué de comment
recommencer la séance parlementaire par
un 49-3 vis-à-vis de l'opinion publique
la uniquement non non ça ne me gêne pas
parce que si on dit clairement les
choses si on explique bien les choses
donc le 49-3 vous savez les brandissent
vous par certains maires dans la
campagne électorale je le sais d'être
accusé de passer aux joueurs sur une
nouvelle fois non mais ne pas passer ne
pas voter la loi de programmation
aujourd'hui c'est faire perdre la France
des millions voire des milliards ce que
vous pensez la réforme des retraites ça
vous paraît pas je crois que c'est
facile courage politique vous savez j'y
appartenu à une majoritaire relative qui
a voté la CSG on nous approchez à
l'époque de lavé à trois voix trois voix
sous Michel regard est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
quelqu'un remettrait en cause le 49-3 de
la CSG personne un mot dessinateur ce
sera dimanche est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet pour votre groupe il sortira
affaibli c'est difficile d'abord je en
tant que président de groupe vous
imaginez bien que je vais pas je vais
vous dire aujourd'hui je vais vous dire
c'est difficile parce que sur les 12
sénateurs sortants 4 ne se représentent
pas dans les secteurs ou c'est déjà pas
facile que pour les autres la campagne
aujourd'hui vous êtes les copains vous
savez les élections intermédiaires c'est
l'occasion pour les électeurs fustiles
des élus de se venger que sur le
gouvernement par contre c'est difficile
d'avoir l'étiquette de la majorité
présidentielle je sais je comment tomber
il y a 3 ans quand j'ai fait campagne
j'ai fait une campagne difficile je le
fais mais je pense que nos candidats
sortants que je connais bien tous que
j'ai vu ici que vous voyez ici parce que
nous sommes un petit groupe mais présent
sur tous les textes présents dans toutes
les interventions ont travaillé et sur
sur le terrain je les connais sur le
terrain aussi donc j'espère et je
souhaite et nous faisons tout pour
qu'ils puissent regarder leur parler de
la majorité ce sera difficile de se
parler de la majorité donc Renaissance
va perdre des sièges et visiblement et
le modem et horizon vont gagner comment
vous expliquer cette différence
ici d'accord bon très bien déjà bon 400
reconduire quatre sortants qui sont bien
implantés têtes de liste qui ont déjà
les électeurs qui ont déjà les électeurs
il me semble que Madame Sempé à Pau elle
a quand même la ville de Pau tous les
électeurs modernes derrière c'est pas le
cas de mes amis que je donne pas de nom
ici aujourd'hui vous avez compris mais
donc nous en l'occurrence et puis en
plus nous en avons quatre tandis qu'il
se représente pas très difficile
aujourd'hui donc déjà là alors ça va se
jouer à deux ou trois sièges ce gars ou
cette perte je pense que les équilibres
du Sénat ils vont bouger sur 30 sièges
ils vont bouger sur 30 mais vous vous
pensez perdre combien pas plus de choses
ce que j'espère c'est que nous restions
à l'étage et que nous en gagnant un ou
deux attention à gagner il y a quand
même des territoires nous pouvons gagner
est-ce que le RN aura des sénateur pour
vous oui je pense que le RN aura 3 à 4
sénateurs ici 3 4 moins que les 5 à 10
donc parlait Gérard Larcher il y a
quelques temps
dernière question Christelle la majorité
et surtout le gouvernement a longtemps
négligé le Sénat ça a été les critiques
de nombreux sénateurs durant le premier
quinquennat est-ce que vous trouvez que
les rapports ont changé aujourd'hui et
est-ce que vous payez aujourd'hui cette
négligence la majorité
c'est le Sénat lui-même qui affirmait à
travers les propos de son président nous
sommes l'opposition
quand vous affirmez tomber nous sommes
l'opposition il vaut mieux que le
gouvernement traite avec sa majorité
aujourd'hui les choses ont effectivement
changé du fait de la majorité relative à
l'Assemblée avec des incertitudes que
vous connaissez autour du groupe les
républicains et alors qu'ici on a vu on
avait ici on a vu au Sénat regarder
qu'avec les républicains on a pu trouver
sur pas loin de 20 textes un accord avec
eux pour le voter et avec la gauche
aussi donc le fait que de commencer je
trouve que c'est bien de commencer par
sur les textes importants comme la loi
immigration que nous avons déjà passé en
commission où nous avons un débat nous
pouvons poursuivre ce débat aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est au ministre de
l'Intérieur à l'heure actuelle et au
ministre de des relations avec le
Parlement de négocier avec les parties
de la majorité du Sénat pour savoir
jusqu'où ils veulent aller et en fin de
compte obtenir au bout un texte qui
permettra d'avancer à la santé merci
François patriar merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin